bonsoir à la norme merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france envers le
voir un mobile raciste de ces attaques
précises n'ont pour le moment pas été
établie formellement mais les crimes 1
contre les asiatiques ont triplé en 2020
selon une étude ça semble incroyable
comme information à ce qu'on ait une
idée des raisons pourquoi c'est à cause
de l ancienne administration et du pays
de la tendance à blâmer une culture pour
le virus aux états unis il est venu même
si nous disons qu'il n'y a pas de motif
racial
les victimes étaient des femmes
asiatiques doute pour moi c'est très
clair et la distance entre les trois
crime montre bien qu'il venait une
certaine catégorie de personnes
alors le président joe biden s'est
emparée de la question il a affirmé que
cette violence contre les américains
d'origine asiatique était très
préoccupante
néron il ne fait pas le lien on est bien
d'accord avec son prédécesseur et ce
pointage des doigts quand au chinese
virus il n'est pas très important qu'un
lien soit établi
ce qui est important c'est de savoir la
façon dont la culture fonctionne et il
est très clair qui a une culture anti
asiatique
le président n'a pas besoin d'établir ce
lien de nous pouvons établir cette
conclusion nous mama il y a eu plus de
violence outre toutes les minorités au
cours de lancer d'administration donc il
n'est pas nécessaire d'établir ce lien
et de nombreuses organisations de
défense en ligne essaye de défendre
justement la population à
si aux américaines est ce la première
fois que la communauté asiatique et pris
ainsi pour cible est ce qu'elle est elle
est plutôt bien d'intégrer aux
etats-unis cette population
l'intégration complète n'existe pas aux
états unis cette communauté a été pris
pour cible a à plusieurs reprises au
cours de l'histoire et toman que
beaucoup de groupes différents par
exemple les japonais qui ont été
internés pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale donc ce n'est pas une nouveauté
etc c'est un fait
aujourd'hui l'autre pays essaye de
traiter des sujets qui ont été laissées
en suspens et le président n'ont pas
résolu nos problèmes et ils ont même été
exacerbée par l'administration
précédente à la norme plus que jamais
l'amérique semble fractures et ont
présenté joe biden comme un président
capable justement d'apaiser un petit peu
les choses à ce que c'est vraiment le
cas il faut que cela signifie certaines
personnes considèrent qu'il faut
accepter de coopérer avec ses
oppresseurs joe biden à un consensus
il faut pouvoir éduquer afin d'améliorer
la situation
la culture le monde du travail
le contexte culturel doit vont
fonctionner de pair et le lac au vide
les problèmes d'argent et les problèmes
de chômage attise les tensions
joe biden est arrivé au pouvoir disant
qu'il allait résoudre des problèmes de
droits civiques
mais le président ne veut pas de rire à
l'espace nice et les états unis qui pas
vous décrire les états unis joe biden
travail mais il nous avançons et on ne
peut pas il m'a s'imaginer directement
dans une utopie
aujourd'hui avec cette campagne de
vaccination aux états unis on imagine
que vous voyez le bout du tunnel a
contrairement à nous autres européens
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas ce que
les choses s'apaisent
de ce point de vue là aux états unis
je pense que la situation devient plus
facile pour certains ceux qui sont bien
à connecter les personnes qui vivent
dans les régions notre public m elles
ont rappelé mois accès au vaccin
moi même je ne fais pas partie des
groupes prioritaires pour la vaccination
mais dans certaines communautés où ils
n'ont pas par exemple d'accès internet
où ils vivent dans des régions rurales
et ne peuvent pas vraiment se déplacer
il ya plus de difficultés je pense que
les etats unis sont en tête
et une fois qu'ils seront résolus ces
problèmes alors dû pourront partager
avec le reste du monde
donc la situation s'améliore mais ça
n'est pas terminée surtout avec
l'apparition de nouveaux variants le
problème sous-jacent continue cependant
oui problème humanitaire tgh emploi ou
de bien-être social merci à la naure
d'avoir été avec nos ports vu de
l'extérieur
ce soir